[Music]
it all started with Man of Steel in 2013
the DC extended Universe was born and
was set to compete with Marvel's MCU the
Superman film adaptation with Henry
caval was a success and the DCU
continued until it finally came to a
close this December with Aquaman in the
lost kingdom cult director James gun
switched from Marvel to DC as the new
boss and intends to shake things up
together with Peter saffran new movies
new actors and new stories welcome to
the DCU and once again at all starts
with Superman the new universe is set to
kick off in 2025 and opens with the
movie Superman Legacy directed and
written by James gun himself there was
already some information about the story
and the cast that we don't want to keep
from you so enjoy our movie
preview although the theatrical release
of Superman Legacy is still some time
away a lot is already known about the
cast and the characters who will feature
in the film this much can already be
said James gun is not really being
economical here the number of
superheroes is almost reminiscent of his
Works Guardians of the G galaxy in the
suicide
squad there is perhaps one thing that
everyone can agree on the movie stands
and falls with the casting of the main
character Clark Kent also known as
Superman he was sent to Earth as a child
from his declining Home Planet Krypton
there he developed into an extraordinary
man with superpowers and soon became
Earth's protector over the years
numerous actors have shaped the role
most notably Christopher reev and Henry
caval in the cinema a tough challenge
for the new actor to take on after a
long selection process David Corin was
ultimately chosen the American actor was
mainly known for minor roles in series
such as House of Cards the politician in
Hollywood him being cast as Superman is
no coincidence in the past he was often
compared to Henry caval due to his size
and looks the latter being an absolute
fan favorite whether cornw can be just
as convincing remains to be
seen where there's Superman there's also
Lois Lane of course the young journalist
is not only Clark's coworker but also
his girlfriend the role of Lois will be
played by Rachel Brosnahan this time
after she was able to hold her own own
against numerous female colleagues rosan
is best known for her leading role in
the series The Marvelous Mrs masel for
which for example she was awarded two
Golden Gloves and
anemy in the first DCU film Superman
will get active support from Hawk Girl
her companion Hawkman was previously
seen in Black adom just like him she
possesses superhuman strength and the
ability to fly her story varies from one
comic to another the first HW girl was
called Shira Sanders Hall and made her
debut in the first issue of Flash comics
in 1940 in it she and her partner hawman
are archaeological explorers who
discover the secret of their
reincarnation she is The Reincarnation
of an Egyptian princess after she's
death Kendra sunders appeared as a new
Reincarnation of Haw girl she has the
same powers and also the memories of her
previous lives in some versions of the
comics Hawk Girl is a member of the
thanagarians an alien species with wings
this version of Hawk Girl can be seen in
several comic adaptations in Animated
Series in addition to her imposing
appearance the character is particularly
striking due to her use of all kinds of
ancient weapons how the character will
be integrated into the plot of Superman
Legacy remains unknown Haw girl will be
played by Isabella mered the young
American is known from movies such as
Transformers the last night and Dora in
the lost city of
gold another superhero we will get to
see in Superman Legacy is Guy Gardner
his introduction promises to be an
exciting one Gardner is a member of the
Green Lanterns who are finally making
their comeback in the DCU the last movie
adaptation of the Green Lanterns from
2011 with Ryan Reynolds was sadly a big
flop fans of the comic original are
therefore all the more excited to
finally see a worthy adaptation Gardner
is one of the oldest Green Lanterns and
first appeared in the comics in 1950 he
is known for his hot-headed and
provocative personality his conflicts
with other superheroes particularly Hal
Jordan and John Stewart are iconic these
aggressive tendencies make him a unique
and complex character in the world of
comics in Superman Legacy he's played by
none other than cult actor Nathan filon
he is known from such series as Firefly
castle and the rookie but has also
worked with James gun on Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 and The Suicide
Squad appearing on the big screen for
the very first time is the superhero
metamorpho also known as Rex Mason he
first popped up in the comic the Brave
and the Bold in 1965 his story is
closely linked to his Supernatural
transformation abilities Rex Mason was a
mercenary and treasure hunter who was
hired by the ruthless Simon stag to find
rare elements during an expedition in
the jungle he's confronted with a
strange gas from outer space called the
metamorpho radiation this transforms him
into a being with amazing powers of
transformation metamorpho can alter his
body into different elements and
substances allowing him to change his
form and abilities as required in
Superman Legacy metamorpho was played by
the American Anthony carrian carrian has
had roles in the DC series Gotham and in
Barry for which he was nominated for an
Emmy also featured is the superhero Mr
terrific AKA Michael Hol he was
originally an outstanding athlete and an
award-winning scientist however his life
took a tragic turn when his wife and
child lost their lives in a car accident
ENT deeply saddened Hol decided to turn
his life in a positive direction and
dedicate himself to fight crime through
intensive study and training not only
did he acquire exceptional knowledge but
also formidable physical fitness he
became a master of technology and
strategy particularly in the field of
nanotechnology and quantum physics he's
often surrounded by small robot spheres
that perform all kinds of tasks for him
and can even make him fly in Superman
Legacy Mr terrific is played by Eddie
gei a Kenyan actor who has already
appeared in such films as X-Men first
Class and in the series For All
Mankind the classic Superman villain Lex
Luthor will serve as the antagonist he
is portrayed by Nicholas Holt who had
previously applied unsuccessfully for
the role of Clark
Kent animal lovers will presumably be
offered a treat in Superman Legacy as
well it looks like crypto the Superdog
will be playing a role in the upcoming
Blockbuster at first dog lover James gun
joked about putting his buddy Chris
Pratt in the project with this part
since then though there have been more
and more signs that Superman's animal
companion will actually make an
appearance the character was last seen
in the animated Adventure DC League of
Super
Pets the script for Superman Legacy has
been finalized and James gun has already
spoken about it the film will focus on
Clark Kent's younger years but is
explicitly not intended to be an origin
story it is more about his Beginnings as
a journalist and how he views other
superheroes from this perspective before
getting involved in the action himself
we wonder above all how gun will
incorporate so many superheroes into one
movie and whether the overall tone of
the DCU will differ from the more somber
DC
with Guardians of the Galaxy and The
Suicide Squad he has already proven that
he can handle many characters within one
movie as well as sad and funny moments
in equal measure the start of shooting
for the film was delayed due to the
actor strike in Hollywood now that this
is ended however nothing stands in the
way of the project it was recently
announced that filming will finally
start in Spring 2024 probably in March
at present the theatrical release of
Superman Legacy is scheduled for July
11th
2025 so that's all the latest
information on the first movie of the
new DCU does the range of superheroes
suit your taste and will you give David
cornat a shot as Henry kav successor let
us know your thoughts in the comments
and don't forget to give us a thumbs up
if you like this
[Music]
video